for both of you I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit about how
Jonathan first proposed this project to
you um how he described it how he
described how it looked how it was going
to look how it was going to sound
basically what what we saw here
tonight um um I had to do a self tape um
to describe myself and to say why I did
become an actor without knowing the
project without knowing the potential
role only knowing it's for a new project
of Jonathan Glazer and I decided to do
it in German because it felt more
natural and I think this was the door
opener to to meet John and his longtime
friend and producer Jim Wilson in a pop
in London and then John shares with me
his vision his thoughts um the potential
role the script and um yeah some rare
photographs of the h family and I didn't
know the this story of this family that
they lived so close to the uh Camp um
with with a swimming pool with a
garden and with their kids and um then I
had a traditional casting with my lovely
colleague Sandra and after that um
Jonathan asked me um it was like a
marriage proposal do you want to be a
part of my uh film and I said
immediately yes because I think his
Vision
um yeah it it it makes sense and it it
was so I was so curious to work with him
and yeah to be a part of his
vision Johnny I was wondering if you
could talk a little about your um your
first impressions um well i' I've known
Jonathan for kind of almost three
decades and um so when he first spoke to
me about the film you know we we went
for a coffee near his house and he was
was basically telling me that that um he
was writing a script and sound was going
to be very key in providing an
extraordinary St contrast between what
you see and what you hear and that um
ultimately really I you know I need to
begin doing some research and
understanding everything about the
sounds that would have been heard at
that place in time and kind of how they
would have been heard so it was um yeah
I think he I think I mean he never asked
me if I would do it because I've sort of
have worked with him for many years but
but yeah it was was um do your research
was was his opening line to me speaking
of research I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about
Christian approaching what your sort of
reaction you put yourself on self tape
you didn't know what it was going to be
for what your reaction when he proposed
playing Rudolph hos and how you sort of
started to approach playing this
man um for me it was the most important
thing where the conversations had with
Jonathan and with Sandra together we had
a lot of conversations we had to
postpone the the filming because of the
co situation for one year and we had
more time for Preparation things and we
had a lot of conversations about um the
script the character um because John
want to connect
our not the whole biography but things
um for example there was in the first
script the scene Rudolph is drunk and I
was never drunk in my life and then
Jonathan decided to cut the scene out
and to change it with another scene and
we were searching together because
Jonathan was from the beginning very
transparent to us with his vision uh
what he's searching for and um and these
conversations for me were the most
important part I read um
has has his biography I heard his voice
his original voice I listened to his
voice from The nck Trial you can hear
the voice at YouTube but you hear a
voice from a prisoner not from a comant
in his prime but it was important for me
to create this character um and then I
had to do some technical things I had to
do uh to learn um horseback riding um um
I had a personal trainer because I had
to lose weight for the summer and gain
weight for the winter and then lose
weight again and it's my body is a
little bit out of control now but it's
um but it was it's a small detail but it
was important for me it was more to dive
into the darkness of this character from
the outside um and um the method we we
shut the mo movie we we we talk L about
that that was helpful too um to create
this character to be spontaneous and
sometimes not knowing too much um about
him more to figure it out in normal
ordinary situations well I mean can you
as you brought up can you talk a little
bit about for the audience who probably
doesn't know how how Jonathan set up the
cameras how he um and how you shot this
movie which is very unique and very
original and Johnny also you know how
that worked from your end um in terms of
collecting that
sound we filmed them the movie with
sometimes 10 cameras
simultaneously um and Jonathan described
it um in the beginning it it's like big
brother in a Nazi house um and it's the
thing that we observing the characters
we following the characters we we
looking through a window and not
following like in a normal movie with a
yeah with a normal camera system and we
had these different cameras in different
angles in different rooms sometimes we
shot in in two or three rooms
simultaneously sometimes um we can hear
our colleagues in the other room and
that was really amazing and every time
every day um the set were was prepared
and we had no uh rehearsals we started
immediately without the break and
without technical interruptions and we
haven't seen uh technicians or um people
from the set on the set because they
were hidden um the focus puller from the
camera where in the basement of the
house and Jonathan and his team uh were
um next to the set in a container with
10 monitors and and Jonathan uh heard um
in one ear the original sound and the
other ear um the translator because he
tried to learn German but it's um a
difficult language and
um yeah um Jonathan stopped immediately
but he he but he had a good feeling for
the language he understand us and we
trust him um a lot because he f um he
felt the right tone or um yeah that was
really amazing uh and he described it
after a take it's all one takes and then
um and we had the freedom to be
spontaneous and that is what what I
meant when I said it's um sometimes you
you read a biography and you know the
psychologically uh psychological things
uh from the character but here sometimes
we had uh one or two scenes per day and
we know okay now today we have a
birthday party or we have a dinner or um
and and then we figure it out together
he had a phenomenal script but he
invites us to figure it out to search
for the truth and and not act in a in a
normal way more we had all the Time in
the World um sometimes to improvise and
sometimes improvisation ation helps us
to dive into the scenes written um in
the script and um that was really
amazing and after that he describes some
things sometimes not sometimes someone
was yelling cut and sometimes not and
then we had a uh shot for one and a half
hour and we had the freedom to decide
okay we try it again or now for example
at the dinner we eat and in
in this moment I start with the lines
again or yeah and that was really
amazing to to shoot in this way Johnny I
was wondering if you could talk a little
bit about sort of you know from your
team's perspective how you figured out
how to capture sound in that house when
you have multiple cameras moving at once
and multiple scenes acting out at the
same time yeah I think um as Christian
says it you know um Jonathan's whole
thing is is to create an environment
where it's as close as possible to to
you know documentary and what actually
happened and allow the actors to to be
as free as possible to not have the
incumbents of technical people hanging
out particularly the children who who
you know might even be more put off and
so certainly yeah there were hidden
microphones um you know there was no
sort of person standing there with a
boom mic or anything it was very much um
planning out where people would be in
the room before before a take and and um
moving the microphones to to to get to
the right position I think it's
interesting that um you know although
there would have been many takes done on
a particular scene they were never
particularly edited between the takes
you know every every shot in the film
every scene was one take um and and
that's what kind of gives it the very
real and authentic feel that that um we
were cutting between camera positions
rather than you know different performan
es or anything and and as far as the
microphones go as you say Christian
there was very much everything was
happening at the same time so there
would there really would be the children
playing outside when Rudolph was lying
on his sofa in the um in the office you
know there was the radio was on and you
could hear um you you could hear the uh
in in the kitchen the women talking and
you could hear the baby crying and you
could hear the children outside and
those were all things that were actually
recorded at the time and so the process
of mixing that was was very much to to
um choose you know what was what existed
and and and that was um yeah that was
very much to do with the creation of um
the family drama which was as John had
described it to me that that really you
know we must create and complete this
extraordinary film and
presentation of what happened there and
then at a later stage in postproduction
introduce this other layer of sound
which they're ignoring basically
well thank you so much for being here
and thank you all for being here I thank
you thank you for
[Applause]
listening